Jocko and Leif, how do you know
if you terminated too early?
I wanted to remove the toxicity
before damaged the team.
When do you know it's
time to fire someone?
So we'll get into a little
little change in pace here,
going from the darkness of the Islamic
state into something a lot more positive,
which is people run in businesses.
And it's good to clarify that because
terminated as a different context and my
gravy, it's, so,
this is a good question and it's something
we hear a lot and we got a ton of
questions when I put this out. So what
do you know? It's time to fire somebody.
We get this question all the
time, as you just said. And it's,
this was always the most difficult thing
and it is incredibly difficult even for,
you know, people who feel like they're
super, super tough leaders, uh,
are strong leaders in the seal teams who
have been through all our training and,
and uh, and have proven themselves on the
battlefield. It's hard to fire people.
It's always difficult to fire people.
It's hard to have those tough
conversations with folks. And so, uh,
we've talked,
we talk about this,
that the right time to fire somebody
is when you don't feel bad about it.
And what I mean by that, I don't mean
just because you're cold blooded,
but that you actually, uh, but that's,
you actually have taken every step to
mentor and train and provide resources
and, and, uh,
help that person achieve the performance
that you need them to achieve in order
to accomplish the mission. And you've
given them every chance to succeed.
And once you, you, you should feel
absolutely confident that you've, you've,
you've exhausted all options and then
you're not going to feel bad about it
cause you've,
you've,
you've taken so much time and effort
and they shouldn't even, they,
they're not even going
to be upset about it.
Not that they necessarily love
you or thank you for firing them.
But so often you see people that are
literally relieved when we work with
companies and we see this happen,
we see people that are relieved because
they're in a position where they just,
they're overwhelmed. There's
massive pressure on them.
And they knew there it was.
It was beyond their capability and they
just didn't want to say, I can't do this.
And so when they got either fired or
just transitioned to a different role,
it was real. They were relieved and they
said, thank you. And I, it really was,
that was really eating at me that I,
I didn't feel capable and I didn't feel,
I knew I was letting the team down.
Uh, and that's almost always the case.
Every once in a while you get the
torture genius who is just can't take
direction or won't listen.
Um, who's never going to see,
never going to see that I'd had,
but that's okay. It's okay. Yeah.
The only other thing I'd say is laying
out the real crystal clear expectations
of where you need to be. Hey, if this is
what you, there's where you need to be.
And if you don't get there,
this is what's going to happen.
And that's why you said it shouldn't
be a surprise. It should be, hey,
I knew exactly what the expectations were.
I knew exactly what was required of me
and I knew exactly what was going to
happen if I didn't meet those
expectations or requirements.
So that's how you know.
And the only other thing is we
sometimes it's totally normal.
We build a relationship with our people.
And so sometimes that relationship gets
strong to the point where you might
value that relationship more than you
value the performance of the team,
then that is not a good situation because
you have to look out for the whole
team. And if I say, Oh, this guy's
not doing his job, but he's my bro,
so I'm going to keep them on,
I'm letting down the whole team.
So that's just another little element
that you have to pay attention to.
And if you truly care about the
person, mentor them, coach them,
put them into position
where they can succeed.
Sometimes people aren't good at something
and you've got to move them to a spot
where they can,
you can take advantage of their strengths
instead of putting him in a spot where
their weaknesses are going
to be totally exposed.
That's how you take care of someone.
So that's what you gotta do
before you fire somebody.
One thing too that I learned
from you in, in, in the navy, uh,
during our time was when you
had those tough conversations,
you got to write it down. You
have to write it down. And
that's something that, uh,
I, I thought was very powerful because
so often even in the seal teams,
you'd see leaders who would say, well,
this leader screwed up, you know,
this platoon commander or this
chiefs got an issue and we need to,
he's causing the,
you know,
he's dangerous or he's
making bad decisions or he's
unprofessional, or, uh, he's,
you know, he's, he's not getting his
unit where, where they need to be and,
and we need to call them
in and tighten him up.
And you'd have that conversation behind
closed doors when the person isn't
present and you're like, right on, let's
call them in, let's tighten them up.
You come in, they sit down and here
you are face to face with that person.
And you just had that closed
her conversation about
how terrible they were and
how they really needed,
you know, we're going to,
we're going to square them away and now
face to face the conversation goes like
this. Well, you're doing,
you're doing a pretty good job,
you're doing a pretty good job overall.
There's a couple things we need to
work on here or there, but, you know,
maybe not here. And, uh, I,
I think that's, uh, that's,
that doesn't help anyway.
That's the false cheerleading
is a disaster. And, um,
it's something that we talk about
all the time and our business,
I'm sure you've mentioned
that on the podcast a, you
know, many times before, but,
uh, when you write it down,
you have it in front of you.
So you have to have that tough
conversation and you give them a copy.
So they have it with them as well.
And then they can take that and understand
where they need to be and when they
need to be there. And, uh, and that forces
you to have those tough conversations.
It's a, it's, it's absolutely
a game changer and makes
you, makes you address that.
And then again,
the false cheerleading is a disaster.
People then when you add to fire
someone and they're like, wait,
you just said I was doing a good job.
So obviously you failed
as a leader in another,
another good thing you can do to soften
the blow of this stuff when you're,
when you're delivering the heavy news is
you're saying, listen, I wrote this down.
I can put this in front of you.
Why am I doing that?
Because I think you can do it. I want
you to do it. I'm investing in you.
This is not my way to,
to make you feel bad.
This is my way to make you get better.
I want you to do better. So here's I,
here's what you gotta do for me.
Here it is in plain English.
Do you understand this bullet point?
That's the best possible
thing you can do and,
and you've got to make them understand
that cause otherwise they'll walk out of
the room saying, all he's picking on me,
he doesn't like me. No, no, no, no, no.
The opposite is true. If I didn't
like you, I would just fire you.
I want you to perform.
I'm mentoring you.
I'm coaching you cause
I want you to do better.
I'm giving you this list so you know
exactly what you have to do to win.
So don't take it the wrong way.
My brother just get in the game
and get this stuff done. Hey,
do you think, cause I remember you
saying this evening Echo, good evening.
I remember you saying this to to jade.
Remember you were like,
you were like when you don't feel, I don't
know if you put in those exact words,
but that's basically the message.
Exactly what they said when you don't feel
bad about it, you guys both know. Yup.
Yup.
Deep.
Do you think that there's a difference
between like the seal teams for example,
because you can't just, well, I'm
assuming you can't just replace the guy,
so it's like it's worth it to
invest as much as you possibly can.
[inaudible] world and the seal teams,
I thought this would be different.
They're not different. They're the
same. So in the civilian world,
every company would go work with,
doesn't matter what the company is there,
there's no immediate replacement.
For somebody that knows a skill
set for a software engineer,
is there a great guy waiting
to come in the door? No.
Is there a great welder waiting
to come to the door? No.
Is there that just no matter
what these things are,
there's not a perfect
replacement coming from,
it's the same thing in the seal teams.
You don't have a ready
replacement ready to come in.
So of course you've got a person, you've
gone through the agony of finding them,
you've gone through the
agony of recruiting them.
You've gone through the agony of bringing
them on board, issuing them their gear,
getting them their computer,
letting them understand the, the,
the culture of the company.
I've done, I've been, you've
already invested so much.
You don't want to just fire the person.
You want them to work out.
And so that's why it's important on either
military and civilian. You've got, um,
you've made those investments. The, the
best outcome is to have them succeed.
That's always the best outcome.
And so that's why you've got to be a great
mentor, a great coach, a great leader.
And I've talked about this before.
I'm not going to go into right now,
but some people are allergic to the word
mentor and some people are allergic to
the word coach. You get some with
an ego problem. And I go, Hey,
life, welcome to the platoon. I'm
gonna go ahead and mentor you.
You know what I mean? I
don't need you to. So, so,
so there's a lot of people
that they think, you know,
that offends them because that implies,
I've said this before,
that implies that I know more than you do.
And you know,
less than me and I'm the big guy that's
going to help you, little guy. Yeah.
So sometimes that direct kind of coaching
is not the right answer, but you know,
clearly when you're getting to a
point where someone's getting fired,
you need to do some direct coaching.
So that's why we're right now.
We're getting it done correctly at one.
One more point on that, which is a great,
uh, a great question, a cobot, but it's,
that's the easiest, I think, fall back.
And we see that with a lot of leaders.
I've seen,
we saw it in the military and
we see it throughout, you know,
companies and organization that we work
with now. Oftentimes it's people that,
well, this person isn't good enough. I
need to fire them and get someone else.
And it, almost, most of the time, that's
not the case. Most of the time it's,
they just need to be led.
They need to be led.
They need to have the mission better
explained to them. They need to have,
you know,
the training.
They need to have a better resource
and they need to have mentorship. Uh,
it just as Jack was talking about. And
so that's, that's an easy fallback,
but it's,
it's an,
it's an excuse and it's the opposite of
extreme ownership and really only the
case of that tortured genius, right?
That, that, that we wrote about the,
the person that just cannot take
any direction no matter how, uh,
how valid, uh, our, our,
uh, our positive, uh,
needed or they can't take any criticism,
they won't accept any responsibility.
They have it all figured out.
The world just can't see the
genius in what they do. You know,
that's kind of how they look at things.
That's the only time that you really have
to fire those, those folks generally.
Yeah. The, and the, the thing
you didn't say, you hit like
four points. You want to,
one of the best places to start,
if someone's not doing what they're
supposed to be doing is explaining to them
why they're doing it. Well, this
is why I want you to do this.
Because then they can absorb it.
They understand what the deep mission is.
They understand kind of
the commander's intent.
So whenever someone's not doing
this, and I, you know what,
I'm going to go ahead and
break out a story right now.
So I got a seven year old daughter.
She can't ride a bike yet,
right? That's not good. You should
be riding a bike at four. Right?
And my family is four, so she can't
ride a bike yet. We're not too. So,
and she's, and it's become a
thing. It's become an issue, right?
So the other day,
and we're going on a big camping trip
and it's going to be necessity to be able
to ride the bike. So the other
day I started telling you, okay,
we got to go work on your bike riding.
So I'm gonna come get your shoes on,
get ready to grow. And she immediately
goes defensive. I don't know.
I don't want to ride a bike. I can't
ride a bike. I'm not good at. Right.
And I started getting right. You
know, no, listen, get your shoes on.
I went that route like an idiot.
And I,
luckily I didn't go too far down that
road and I just stopped myself after two
direct orders with no explanation
of why. And I said, hey sweetie,
we're going to go work on your bike ride.
Let me tell you why.
Because when we go camping,
almost everywhere we're going to be
going is going to be on the bike,
especially when it's time to
bike ride to go get an ice cream.
We're going to have to ride
bikes to get ice cream and,
and so all I want to make sure that
you're able to come with us when we go to
get ice cream. You know, I mean, I don't
want to have to bring it back for you.
I want you to come with us
and you could see, you know,
I just completely to change
attack. And she was said, you know,
okay,
let me get my shoes on.
And literally that's an example with a
seven year old, right? And first of all,
the first note there is that I most are
big leadership expert completely went
down the wrong road and was like,
listen to me because I'm the father
and I know you do what I tell you.
It's the wrong approach 100% of the time.
Even when the seven year old and as
soon as I went back and said, hey,
here's why I want you to end, you know,
I told her a bunch of other things,
you know, it's really good at this
is how we're going to do get around.
This is how you can get around the beach
and all these things and changed her
attitude. It literally changed
her attitude in a minute.
I wish I would have videotaped the whole
thing cause we could have posted it.
Yup. Yeah. That would've been
a good little case study. Yeah.
Flying through with the ice cream money.
The would you say back to the, the high,
the hiring and people,
you know,
you don't have just someone waiting
in the wings to get hired to fill that
position. Remember, um,
that kind of is the case.
Most of the time where if
you fire someone, it's like,
oh, we'll just replace him.
Right? All that work and stuff.
You got to rehire somebody,
been that you're wasting time
and resources to do that.
And you could just be investing
more in that guy. Always want your,
your team to succeed.
And sometimes people take that too far.
You get someone that just wants the
team to see why they're not gonna fire
somebody. So there's always
a balance. There's always
getting on me there. But yes,
that is true. So do you make the exception
if let's say, you know, let's say, hey,
I hired this. I don't know, you
weigh it. You weigh the pros.
So if you do have a guy kind of waiting
in the wings, I don't know my neighbor,
you know,
of course he's willing to say,
you're going to invest less than this
guy because we got this guy ready to go.
Well, no, you won't invest less.
You're not gonna invest anything.
If you've got someone that's going to
come in and do the job and this person
can't make it happen as failed, right.
Currently get rid of them. Yeah,
Jack,
there you go.